I can't tell anything from this
where are we standing standing right
over there
showcases look didn't find anything
because I don't think he was standing
there
rip
bit my rifle
there you go
Are you standing no and I was kneeling
you sure you were here I'm sure it's
there
give it to me
give it to me
okay
just forgot to pick this up sure
that's evidence where'd you find it
this time no [ __ ]
where he said
not where rip said
it was about 15 yards
pretty damn close [ __ ] close enough for
me
that is self-defense Sheriff
I have no idea why
you would want to go ahead and disguise
that
I forgot I picked it up okay Jesus
Christ gentlemen
what are you up to I ain't up to [ __ ]
and that showcase you may get him out
the hook with fish and wildlife but I
just put two dead bodies out of that can
and I had taken your muscles word about
what happened
uh Beth we're closed at the moment
oh
my sister-in-law
I'm no lawyer but I believe it's the
Fourth Amendment that deals with
unlawful search and seizure the search
is voluntary it sure doesn't look
voluntary to me
foreign
I went to high school with you
and you
you babysat her husband
on her driver's license her last name
was long I doubt that's gonna save you
buddy
thank you
wait
don't go
you'll miss all the fun
while I'm here
I might as well shop
oh that's nice
now
not for me
you out of your mind
get back
get back all right get back before that
thing eats somebody
he's friendly he's not
I get back
we won't get any closer
see that fence that's mine that [ __ ]
fence down there that's mine too
everything this side of that mountain
all the way over to here
mine too
you're trespassing all right
trespassing
yeah
they don't believe you
said hi YouTube
what's he saying
says that it's wrong for one man to own
all this
he says you should share with all the
people yeah
this is America
we know sure land here
you can't be here
it's private property
this is National Park
that's National Park
this
is the Dutton Ranch
science says Yellowstone got a big
[ __ ] y on it the Y is for the
Yellowstone Ridge you said Dutton Ranch
it's the Yellowstone Dr Ranch listen I
need you to move
across the room
but I'm gonna have to cite you
for trespass
[Music]
that badge says livestock agent that's
right oh it's [ __ ] cow police
look at this pink-haired hick Mad Dog in
me you got a problem [ __ ] the [ __ ] you
just say to me I called you a [ __ ]
brother
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] kidding
[ __ ]
foreign
which one of these [ __ ] is the boss
of you which one of these [ __ ]
the big guy with the beard
oh
I'm gonna give you one last chance you
leave now or you'll never leave I'll
bury you will you [ __ ] stand
we weren't bothering anyone just having
some fun this feels mine
that fence mine
you damaged both then you came back to
damage him more
foreign
if I did this to your home what would
you do
well I'd kill you
that's right
man said if you didn't leave
we bury you here
and you didn't leave
we keep our word in this Valley
fun we'll leave no it's too late for
that I said we'll leave
I don't want you to leave
I want you to dig
the sun's starting to heat up the sky so
all right that's enough
nobody said get out
yeah
not much point in there
I have children so do I from what I've
seen years will be better off without
you
foreign
figures
foreign
[Music]